Speaking of psychology is taking a winter break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past. In June, I talked to psychologist Adam Alter about how to get unstuck when you're feeling stalled in a job, a relationship, or any other aspect of your life. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of psychology, we'll be back in January with new episodes. Thank you for listening. All of us know the feeling of being stuck. Maybe you're stuck in a job that feels unfulfilling or in a relationship that's making you unhappy. Maybe you're stuck because you want to finish the novel you're working on or learn to speak another language or turn your hobby into a business,
《心理学话题》（Speaking of Psychology）目前正在度过冬歇期，因此我们将重播过去备受听众喜爱的一期节目。今年六月，我采访了心理学家亚当·奥尔特（Adam Alter），探讨了当你在工作、人际关系或生活的其他方面感到停滞不前时，如何摆脱困境。我们希望你能喜欢这期精选自档案馆的节目。《心理学话题》将于一月带着全新节目回归。感谢您的收听。我们所有人都经历过那种陷入困境的感觉。也许你被困在了一份缺乏成就感的工作中，或者在一段让你感到不快乐的关系中；也许你被困住了，因为你想完成正在创作的小说、学会说一门外语，或者把你的爱好变成一门生意，
but you just can't seem to make it happen no matter how many attempts you try. So is getting stuck just an inevitable part of life? Are there things you can do to set yourself up for getting stuck less often? How do you know when it's time to quit versus push ahead? And when you do feel stuck, what practical tips can you take to get past the mental, emotional, and other hurdles standing in your way? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Adam Alter, a professor of marketing at New York University's Stern School of Business.
但无论你尝试了多少次，事情似乎就是没有进展。那么，陷入困境只是生活不可避免的一部分吗？有没有什么方法可以让你尽量减少陷入困境的频率？你如何知道什么时候该放弃，什么时候该坚持？当你真的感到困境时，你可以采取哪些实用的小建议来克服阻碍你前进的精神、情感以及其他障碍？欢迎收听《心理学话题》，这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是纽约大学斯特恩商学院（New York University's Stern School of Business）市场营销学教授亚当·奥尔特博士，
and an affiliate faculty member in the NYU Psychology Department. He is a social psychologist with a particular interest in how subtle cues in the environment can affect human cognition and behavior. He's the author of three books, including The New York Times Best Seller, Irresistible, The Rise of Addictive Technology and the Business of Keeping Us Hooked, which is about the perils of technology addiction. More recently, he has been studying how people and organizations get stuck and how they can get unstuck. His newest book published in May is called Anatomy of a Breakthrough, How to Get Unstuck When It Matters Most. Dr. Alter has also written for The New York Times, The New Yorker, and The Washington Post, among other publications, and has consulted with dozens of companies and organizations around the
他同时也是纽约大学心理学系的兼职教员。他是一名社会心理学家，对环境中的微妙线索如何影响人类的认知和行为有着特殊的兴趣。他是三本书的作者，其中包括《纽约时报》畅销书《不可抗拒：上瘾技术的兴起与让我们欲罢不能的商业本质》（Irresistible: The Rise of Addictive Technology and the Business of Keeping Us Hooked），该书讲述了技术成瘾的危害。最近，他一直在研究个人和组织是如何陷入困境以及如何摆脱困境的。他于五月份出版的新书名为《突破的剖析：在最重要的时候如何摆脱困境》（Anatomy of a Breakthrough: How to Get Unstuck When It Matters Most）。奥尔特博士还为《纽约时报》、《纽约客》和《华盛顿邮报》等出版物撰稿，并曾为全球数十家
world. Dr. Alter, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me, Kim. I gave a few examples of different kinds of stuck just a moment ago, being stuck. in work in a relationship or in some kind of a creative endeavor. Now, when you think about being stuck, what's the common thread that ties all of these experiences together? I'm interested in particular kinds of stuckness. I'm especially interested in protracted or chronic stuckness. So these are occasions where people feel stuck for sometimes months, sometimes years, sometimes even decades, or for sometimes, in some cases, their entire lives. So that's what I'm interested in. But I'm also
公司和组织提供咨询。奥尔特博士，非常感谢您今天能作客节目。非常感谢邀请我，金。我刚才举了几个不同困境的例子，比如在工作、人际关系或某种创意活动中陷入困境。现在，当你思考“陷入困境”时，把所有这些经历联系在一起的共同线索是什么？我对某种特定类型的困境特别感兴趣。我尤其对长期或慢性的困境感兴趣。这些都是人们有时会感到被困数月、数年、数十年，甚至在某些情况下是一生之久的时刻。这就是我感兴趣的地方。但我也
specifically interested in cases where we have some agency. You know, during the early days of the pandemic in 2020, a lot of us couldn't travel, we couldn't do a lot of the things we wanted to do, we were therefore stuck. That wasn't as psychologically interesting to me as a case where we do we do, we do have the power to act. There is something we can do. There aren't government regulations preventing us from doing a certain thing we want to be able to do. And it turns out the vast majority of these occasions of stuckness where people feel they'd like to be in a different situation that often goes on for a long time, most of those cases we do have some agency over. And so I'm very interested in this book and in general in my research in trying to figure out
特别关注那些我们拥有一定自主权的情况。你知道，在2020年大流行之初，我们很多人无法旅行，无法做许多我们想做的事情，因此我们被困住了。这在心理学上对我来说没有那种我们确实有行动能力的案例那么有趣。有些事情是我们能做的。并没有政府法规阻止我们去做我们想做的事。事实证明，在绝大多数这类困境中——人们觉得如果能处于另一种情境中会更好，而且这种情况往往持续了很长时间——对于其中大多数情况，我们其实是拥有一定自主权的。因此，我在这本书中以及总的来说在我的研究中，都非常希望能弄清楚
how we can get unstuck from those situations that tend to plague us for long periods of time. How common is it to feel stuck? I know you've done some surveys to study this. Does getting stuck happen to everyone, at least occasionally? Yes, absolutely. Does it happen more to some people than others? I haven't really looked at individual differences in how often people are stuck, but I've been very interested in how common stuckness is in general.
我们该如何摆脱那些长期困扰我们的情境。感到困境有多普遍？我知道你做过一些调查来研究这个问题。陷入困境会发生在大局每个人身上吗，至少偶尔会发生？是的，绝对会。有些人比其他人更容易陷入困境吗？我其实并没有研究过人们陷入困境频率的个体差异，但我一直对困境普遍有多普遍非常感兴趣。
One of the surveys I've been running for several years now has looked at people around the world and asked them a simple question once I define what it is to be stuck, whether there's any area of their lives where they feel stuck. And what's fascinating to me is that the vast majority, I'd say over 90% of them within 10, 15 seconds, start typing a response. And so they're very quick to be able to draw to mind these occasions or instances or areas in which they feel stuck, which suggests that they're quite prominent, they're top of mind, they're a big part of what it is to be alive. And so I think of stuckness as ubiquitous.
我多年来一直在进行的其中一项调查，是对世界各地的人们进行观察，在一旦我定义了什么是陷入困境之后，问他们一个简单的问题：在他们的生活中是否有任何领域让他们感到困境。让我着迷的是，绝大多数人——我可以说超过90%的人——在10到15秒内就开始键入回答。因此，他们能够非常迅速地在脑海中浮现出这些他们感到被困住的时刻、事件或领域，这表明它们非常显眼，是他们脑海中最优先的事情，也是生存体验中很大的一部分。因此，我认为陷入困境是无处不在的。
You talk in the book about how people are more likely to get stuck in the middle of a project rather than at the beginning or at the end. Why is that? Yeah, this is some interesting research that looks at goal pursuit and the relationship between goal pursuit and motivation. And what it basically suggests is that at the beginning of a task, you're energized, you're usually interested in what you're doing, you bring a lot of good resources to bear on the task. You can imagine any long task, any protracted goal where at the beginning, the fact that you're even starting it usually means that you have a little bit of wind behind your sails. And so that pushes you ahead. At the end of the task, as you can see the finish line, either metaphorically or literally in some
你在书中谈到，人们更有可能在项目的中途而不是在开始或结束时陷入困境。这是为什么呢？是的，有一些有趣的研究探讨了目标追求以及目标追求与动机之间的关系。它基本上表明，在任务开始时，你是充满活力的，通常对你正在做的事情感兴趣，并且会为任务投入大量优质资源。你可以想象任何长期任务，任何长期的目标，在开始时，你甚至开始做这件事的事实通常意味着你的顺风顺水。这会推动你前进。在任务结束时，当你看到终点线时，无论是在隐喻上还是在某些情况下字面上看，
cases, you get another burst of energy because you're sort of drawn almost magnetically to that finish line. But for protracted goals, I liken it a bit to sailing across the ocean between North America and Europe, that you're spending a huge period of time in the middle there between, say, New York and Southampton where you're unable to measure progress. If there is progress, and there may well be progress, it's very, very hard to get a sense of that progress because there are no real signposts or markers in the middle of the ocean. And often in, long protracted goals, especially in the middle of those goals, you don't have the same sense of progress, and that can be demotivating. And so there tends to be this quite predictable lull in
你都会获得另一股能量爆发，因为你几乎像受到磁铁吸引一样被吸引到那个终点线。但对于长期的目标，我有点把它比作横渡北美和欧洲之间的海洋，你在纽约和南安普顿之间的中间地带度过了很长一段时间，在这个阶段你无法衡量进展。如果有什么进展，也可能确实有进展，但要感知这种进展是非常非常困难的，因为大洋中间没有真正的路标或标记。而且通常在长期的目标中，尤其是在这些目标的中途，你不会有那种强烈的进展感，这可能会削弱动力。因此，在长期目标的中间阶段，往往会出现这种相当可预测的动机低谷。这不仅适用于人类。
motivation during the middle part of long protracted goals. And that's not just true of humans. It's true of lower-order animals as well, but it's certainly very prominent in human behavior. So is one of the tricks to pace yourself? I mean, is that something that can help people not get stuck in the middle of something if they know that they're going to chunk the job down into discrete pieces. Yeah, so part of it is pacing yourself. There's a really interesting phenomenon known as telio anticipation, which is literally the anticipation of the end. And so what we're supposed to do with protracted goals is to sort of work out either explicitly or implicitly at the beginning of that process, how much energy will I need in total and how should I best apportion that energy across the
对低等动物来说也是如此，但在人类行为中肯定非常突出。那么，诀窍之一是调整自己的节奏吗？我的意思是，如果人们知道自己将把工作拆分成不同的独立部分，这能帮助他们不在某个事情的中途陷入困境吗？是的，部分原因是要调整自己的节奏。有一个非常有趣的现象叫做“目的论预期”（telio anticipation），它字面意思就是对终点的预期。因此，对于长期目标，我们应该做的是在那个过程开始时，以显式或隐式的方式计算出总共需要多少能量，以及我们应该如何在整个目标过程中最好地分配这些能量。但这确实是一个非常困难的问题。而且往往存在很多不确定性。所以你刚才简短描述的是另一种选择，那就是与其把目标看作是一个大目标，不如把它分解或更窄地划分为子目标。
course of the goal. But that's a really difficult problem. And there's often a lot of uncertainty. So what you've described briefly there is another alternative, which is instead of just thinking of the goal as one big goal, you break it down or bracket it more narrowly into sub-goals. And the beauty of that is that instead of thinking of it as one long goal with a very big middle, if you make those chunks small enough, you sort of lose the middle, you eradicate the middle. And so then you have a start, you have a finish, you have a start, you have a finish, and you repeat that process. If you think about writing a book, for example, it's maybe 100,000 words, which is overwhelming. There's a big middle there. but if you think of it instead as say, you know, 100 periods of writing a thousand words each, the middle in each of those thousand word chunks is much smaller.
这样做的好处是，与其把它看作是一个有着非常漫长中间阶段的长目标，不如把这些区块做得很小，你某种程度上就消除了中间阶段，消除了中间部分。然后你就有了一个起点，一个终点；一个起点，一个终点，你重复这个过程。例如，如果你考虑写一本书，它可能需要10万字，这让人感到压抑。中间有一个漫长的过程。但如果你把它想象成，比如说，100个各写1000字的周期，那么这每一个1000字区块里的中间部分就要小得多。
And so you tend not to have such a pronounced lull. You also talk in the book about what you call the creative cliff. What do you mean by that term? Yeah, so it's actually, it's not the creative cliff so much as the creative cliff illusion. And it's an illusion that people have that we believe that we be. become less creative over time when we're trying to think of creative solutions to a problem. So an example of this might be something like there's a new soft drink company and you're working at a company and your job is to come up with good slogans for this new soft drink company.
因此你往往不会经历那么明显的低谷。你还在书中谈到了你所说的“创意悬崖”（creative cliff）。你这个词是什么意思？是的，其实与其说是创意悬崖，不如说是“创意悬崖错觉”。这是一种人们拥有的错觉，即我们相信随着时间的推移，当我们试图为一个问题寻找创造性解决方案时，我们的创造力会变得越来越差。所以这方面的例子可能类似于，有一家新的软饮料公司，你在一家公司工作，你的工作是为这家新的软饮料公司想出好的标语。
If I said to you, do you think your best ideas will come in the first 10 slogans you come up with or in the next set of 10 between 11 and 20? And the vast majority of people say, well, the stuff that comes easily to me tends to come early. It's going to be harder as I go along. and I generally associate ease with skill, with fluency, with ability. And so just as with learning a language, the more fluent I am with the language, the easier it will come to me.
如果我对你说，你认为你最好的创意会出现在你想出的前10个标语中，还是在11到20之间的下一组10个中？绝大多数人会说，嗯，那些对我来说轻而易举就想到的东西往往出现得很早。随着我继续下去，事情会变得越来越难。而且我通常把轻松等同于技能、流利和能力。因此，就像学习一门语言一样，我对这门语言越流利，它对我来说就越容易。
And so I assume the same about creativity. What turns out to be true, though, is the reverse, which is that it's when things start getting hard, that your ideas become more creative. Instead of there being a cliff over which your creativity tumbles, you sort of lift off, you lift off from the ground at the point where things start to get hard. And so we have this sort of classic problem in human psychology is misinterpreting the signals around us to suggest that we should either quit or that we've already, our best is behind us. And in this case, explicitly the reverse is true, where we tend to do much better with creative tasks only after they start to become difficult. Is it also common for people to hit plateaus in life?
所以我对创造力也做出同样的假设。然而，事实证明恰恰相反，当事情开始变得困难时，你的创意才会变得更有创造力。你的创造力不是从悬崖上跌落，而是在事情开始变得困难的那一刻从地面腾空而起。因此，我们在人类心理学中遇到了这种典型的问题，即误解我们周围的信号，从而暗示我们应该放弃，或者我们最辉煌的时期已经过去。而在这种情况下，情况恰恰相反，通常只有在创造性任务开始变得困难之后，我们才会做得更好。人们在生活中陷入瓶颈期也很常见吗？
And is a plateau the same as being stuck, or is it just a variant? or are you just sort of cruising along at one steady level? Yeah, so a plateau is really where the returns that you're getting from a particular strategy stop arriving, or they shrink in size. So this might be, for example, there's a very famous example of this, looking at people who are sedentary and then they get an exercise regime and then they're tracked for a seven-year period. What you find is that these people tend to make gains for the first 12 to 18 months,
瓶颈期和陷入困境是一回事，还是只是一种变体？或者你只是以一种稳定的水平在巡航？是的，所以瓶颈期实际上是你从特定策略中获得的收益停止到来，或者它们的规模在缩小的情况。这可能是一个非常著名的例子，比如观察那些久坐不动的人，然后他们开始制定锻炼计划，接着对他们进行为期七年的追踪调查。你会发现这些人往往在头12到18个月内取得进展，
but almost universally the same thing that they've been doing. that was really useful for 12 to 18 months becomes less useful beyond that. So they need to change what they're doing. The same is true for learning and for memory and memorization techniques, that we see a similar situation happening when you're, for example, trying to learn a language, that if you keep using the same strategy, it becomes less effective over time. And that's an example of plateau. So it could be that you hit a wall.
但几乎所有人一直在做的、对前12到18个月非常有用同一件事，在那个期限之后变得不那么有用了。所以他们需要改变他们正在做的事情。这对于学习、记忆和记忆技巧来说也是一样的，当我们看到类似的情况发生时，比如你试图学习一门语言，如果你一直使用相同的策略，它随着时间的推移会变得越来越不有效。这就是瓶颈期的一个例子。所以这可能是你撞上了南墙。
That's one possibility. That's the sort of extreme version. But the alternative is that just the marginal gains you get from further effort. decline over time to the point where you're just not getting quite as much back, whereas formerly the same technique was really beneficial. So that's how I generally think of plateaus. They don't have to be that you stop making progress altogether, but you certainly slow down. Let's talk about some of the advice you offer in the book, because there's quite a lot there, and it's very good. One thing you advise is to talk to other people when you're feeling stuck,
这是一种可能性。那是那种极端的形式。但另一种选择是，通过进一步努力获得的边际收益随着时间的推移而下降，以至于你得到的回报不再那么多，而过去同样的技巧曾经非常有用。这就是我通常对瓶颈期的看法。它们不一定意味着你完全停止了取得进展，但你确实放慢了速度。让我们来谈谈你在书中提供的一些建议，因为里面有很多内容，而且非常好。你提供的建议之一是，当你感到困境时，要与其他交谈，
especially to people who are unlike yourself. Why is that helpful? Yeah, it's a tremendous resource that humans have that really other animals do not have. We have a tremendous social network to draw upon when we're stuck. And if you speak to people who are like you, who have the same background, perhaps the same expertise, maybe they've trained the same way, maybe they grew up in the same place, maybe they have the same demographic characteristics, you'll find that they will magnify whatever you've been doing. So if you're doing something well, they will probably tell you to keep doing it or they'll
特别是与那些与你不同的人交谈。为什么这很有帮助？是的，这是人类拥有的一项巨大资源，而其他动物确实没有。当我们陷入困境时，我们可以利用一个庞大的社交网络。如果你和那些与你相似的人交谈，他们有着相同的背景、或许相同的专业知识、也许接受过相同的培训、也许在同一个地方长大、也许拥有相同的统计学人口特征，你会发现他们会放大你一直在做的事情。所以如果你正在做某件好事，他们可能会告诉你继续做下去，或者他们会
help you keep doing it. But if you're stuck, by definition, you might get more entrenched in your stuckness by speaking to people who are like you because they'll magnify that stuckness. The best thing you can do is you can speak to people who are either different from you. The technical term is non-redundant. In other words, there's no overlap. Or you can talk to people who actively push back on your ideas if you're open to that. And the value of that is, instead of having 10 overlapping minds, if you speak to 10 people
帮助你继续这样做。但如果你陷入困境，根据定义，通过与和你相似的人交谈，你可能会更深地陷入困境，因为他们会放大这种困境。你能做的最好的事情就是与那些与你不同的人交谈。技术术语是“非冗余的”（non-redundant）。换句话说，没有重叠。或者，如果你愿意接受的话，你可以和那些积极反驳你想法的人交谈。这样做的价值在于，你不是拥有10个重叠的大脑，而是与10个人交谈
who all see life a little bit differently, you're getting 10 individuals. independent sources of wisdom. And then your job really is just to comb through those 10 different sets of ideas and to figure out what works best for you. And so the idea there, as with much of what I talk about in the book, is that quality and quantity are strongly related. And so if you get more ideas, if you have more people sharing ideas that are distinct, you're more likely to find some good ones. Another piece of advice that you offer, which seems to apply particularly to being stuck in a creative endeavor, is to take the pressure. off yourself to come up with things that are entirely new and unique and instead to think about
他们每个人对生活的看法都略有不同，你将获得10个独立智慧的源泉。然后，你的工作实际上只是梳理这10套不同的想法，并找出最适合你的方法。因此，正如我在书中讨论的大多数内容一样，这里的核心思想是质量和数量密切相关。因此，如果你获得更多的想法，如果有更多的人分享独特的想法，你更有可能找到一些好点子。你提供的另一个建议，似乎特别适用于陷入创意活动的人，那就是卸下压力
recombining ideas. Can you talk about that? Yeah, this is one of the ideas that I came across. I love the arts in general, but I particularly love music. And I've always been really interested in this question that's now become a legal issue in a lot of cases, which is, are people stealing from others. Our artists stealing their ideas, their songs, their melodies, their chords and so on from other artists who've written music in the past. And when you speak to experts, they'll tell you that almost never does that happen. It's very rare for someone to say, I'm going to rip off this other artist because it's often transparent. It leads them to hot water. It's not a good idea professionally. And so I don't think that happens very often. But I think what does happen is we are constantly
不要要求自己想出完全崭新和独特的东西，而是去思考如何重新组合想法。你能谈谈这个吗？是的，这是我偶然发现的想法之一。我总体上热爱艺术，但我尤其热爱音乐。我一直对这个问题非常感兴趣，这个问题现在在很多情况下已经成为一个法律问题，那就是人们是否在盗窃其他人的成果。艺术家是否在从过去创作音乐的其他艺术家那里盗窃他们的想法、歌曲、旋律、和弦等等。当你与专家交谈时，他们会告诉你这种情况几乎从未发生过。某个人说“我要剽窃这位其他艺术家”的情况非常罕见，因为这通常是显而易见的。这会让他们陷入麻烦。在职业上这不是一个好主意。所以我不认为这种情况经常发生。但我认为确实发生的是我们一直在
borrowing. You use the term recombining, which is a term that I use in the book, we're essentially taking two unoriginal ideas, but putting them together in a way that is original. We're recombining them in a way that's new. So I think true radical novelty is vanishingly rare in creative pursuits, but I think what's much more common and what is often a better thing to strive for, a better aim to strive for is to say, I think what I want to do is find two things that have never been combined in a particular way and combine them in that way and see if that brings me value. What's really interesting to me is, as I was doing research for this book, I wanted to sort of figure out who is the closest to being radically original. And if we
借用。你使用了“重新组合”（recombining）这个词，这也是我在书中使用的词，我们本质上是采用两个非原创的想法，但以一种原创的方式将它们组合在一起。我们以一种新的方式将它们重新组合。因此，我认为真正的彻底新颖性在创意追求中是极其罕见的，但我认为更常见的是，而且往往是一个更好的奋斗目标、更好的追求目标，那就是：我想做的是找到两个从未以特定方式结合过的事物，然后以这种方式将它们结合起来，看看这是否能带给我价值。令我真正感兴趣的是，在为这本书做研究时，我想要弄清楚谁最接近彻底的原创。如果我们
traced back far enough, could we find that their originality breaks down at a certain point? One of the examples that comes up very often for people is Bob Dylan. A lot of musicians say Dylan's a genuine, true, radical original. But if you look at Dylan's own words and you look at where his music comes from, even Dylan, as original as he is, was cobbling together a whole lot of different styles. And he himself recognized that so much of his work was building on the folk tradition, for example. And so you do this with art, you can do it with filmmaking. It's just very, very rare to find radical originality. And so recombining elements tends to be the better way to go. Did you find any radical originals?
追溯得够远，我们是否能发现他们的原创性在某个特定点上会瓦解？人们经常提到的一个例子是鲍勃·迪伦（Bob Dylan）。许多音乐家说迪伦是一个真正的、彻底的原创。但如果你看看迪伦自己的话，看看他的音乐从何而来，即使迪伦再怎么原创，他也一直在拼凑大量不同的风格。他自己也承认他的很多作品都是建立在民谣传统的基础之上的，例如。所以你对艺术这样做，你也可以对电影制作这样做。要找到彻底的原创是非常非常罕见的。因此，重新组合各种元素往往是更好的选择。你有没有发现任何彻底的原创？
No, not really, to be honest. I think if you go back far enough, You do find the lineage of almost every idea in someone else's work. The person who invented the wheel or fire. Yeah, I'm sure even before the invention of the wheel, there was someone pushing around something slightly oblong shaped. Someone who invented the wheel saw that and said, hey, I've got an idea. They may have thought it was original,
没有，说实话，真的没有。我想如果你追溯得足够远，你会发现几乎每个想法的血统都可以追溯到别人的作品中。发明轮子或火的那个人。是的，我相信甚至在发明轮子之前，就有人在推着某种略呈椭圆形的东西。发明轮子的人看到了那一幕，然后说：“嘿，我有个主意。”他们可能觉得这是原创的，
but it was just an iteration, an evolution rather than a revolution. What other phenomenon that you talk about in the book has to do with pivoting. And you tell some really great stories about people who are engaged in looking for something. Your job is to maybe invent a drug and you never get there. But then suddenly you discover that something that you found was radically different, but marketable. Can you talk about some of those examples? Because I think the examples you have throughout the book are really rich and interesting. Thank you. Yeah. I think what happens a lot of the time, if you're looking for something, if you're trying to make, say it's a clinical drug that you're making
但这只是一种迭代，是一种进化，而不是革命。你在书中讨论的另一个现象与“转型”（pivoting）有关。你讲了一些非常精彩的故事，关于那些致力于寻找某些东西的人。你的工作可能是发明一种药物，而你从未实现目标。但随后突然间你发现你找到的东西是完全不同但具有市场价值的。你能谈谈其中一些例子吗？因为我认为你在整本书中举的例子都非常丰富和有趣。谢谢。是的。我认为很多时候，如果你在寻找某种东西，如果你在努力制造，假设是你正在制造的一种临床药物
or you're searching for some form of originality or success, whether you're an entrepreneur or an artist, it doesn't really matter what you're doing, is you become very heavily invested in the thing that you're working on. You pour your heart and soul into it. And the golfer Sam Sneed, who is known for having the most beautiful swing of all time, describe the process of swinging the golf club as cradling a bird. You don't want to cradle it so lightly that it flies away, but if you cradle it with too much force, you end up crushing it. And that's kind of how I think the best, most nimble minds think about their ideas,
或者你在寻找某种形式的原创性或成功，无论你是一个企业家还是一个艺术家，你做什么其实并不重要，那就是你会对你正在做的事情投入大量的情感。你倾注了你的心血。高尔夫球手萨姆·斯尼德（Sam Sneed）以拥有史上最美妙的挥杆动作而闻名，他将挥杆高尔夫球杆的过程描述为“像是在怀里呵护一只鸟”。你不能握得太轻，以至于它飞走了，但如果你用力过猛，最终会把它捏碎。这就是我所认为的最好的、最敏捷的头脑对他们想法的看法，
that you don't want to be too flighty. You want to pursue the idea as far as you can, but you need to be open to the possibility that you're wrong or that a slight tweak would improve your returns dramatically. And that's what I kept finding over and over again. A lot of the cases that come up in the history of science are chemists who are exploring new drugs. And there are so many examples of chemists who, for example,
你不想太轻浮。你想尽可能地推进这个想法，但你需要对以下可能性保持开放态度：你是错的，或者稍微调整一下就能大大提高你的回报。这就是我不断一遍又一遍发现的事情。科学史上的许多案例都是探索新药物的化学家。有太多的化学家例子，例如，
accidentally some of the drug they were working with got on their tongues and they tasted this substance and realized that, A, it wasn't poisonous because they still were alive. And B, that it was really, really sweet. And they didn't realize this. And so a lot of the artificial sweetness that have then made companies, you know, billions of dollars over the years, come from these kind of accidental discoveries. Now, a lot of people are not receptive to that kind of serendipity. But if you are, if you look for it, if you're always open to the idea that you might be wrong. There are certain people who are just very good at capitalizing on, seizing on these moments. And it's not just about chemistry. It's about art as well, and it's about business. And you see a
他们无意中将正在研究的一些药物沾到了舌头上，他们品尝了这种物质并意识到：A，它不是毒药，因为他们还活着；B，它真的非常非常甜。而他们之前并没有意识到这一点。因此，多年来为公司带来数十亿美元利润的许多人造甜味剂，都来自于这种偶然的发现。现在，许多人对这种偶然性并不买账。但如果你买账，如果你去寻找它，如果你总是对“自己可能是错的”这一想法保持开放态度。有些人非常擅长利用、抓住这些时刻。这不仅关乎化学。这也关乎艺术，关乎商业。你会看到
lot of these cases of people pivoting in ways that ended up being very, very profitable for them. I want to talk for a moment about the idea of writers' block. I would imagine that all of our listeners have heard the term and maybe have experienced it, whether they were in college and they had to write a term paper or maybe in their jobs today where you have an assignment to produce a big report. Is there really such a thing as writer's block or is it just that people can't get started? And what are the techniques that can get you unstuck in that kind of a situation? Yeah, it's so funny because this is a term that I always took for granted. I assumed that it was a concept that was well recognized, that everyone agreed, yes, there was something called writers block
很多这样的人以最终对他们非常非常有利的方式进行转型。我想花点时间谈谈“作家之块”（writer's block，即写作梗阻）的概念。我想我们所有的听众都听说过这个词，并且可能都经历过，无论他们是在大学里必须写学期论文，还是在今天的工作中必须完成一份大报告的任务。真的存在所谓的写作梗阻吗，还是人们只是无法开始？有哪些技巧可以让你在这种情况下摆脱困境？是的，这太搞笑了，因为这是一个我一直认为理所当然的词。我以为这是一个广为人知的概念，每个人都同意，是的，确实有某种叫做写作梗阻的东西
or at least some version of it. But it's such a polarizing term because you speak to some writers and they say, oh, I have no idea what you're talking about. That's a ridiculous concept, and I just sit down and I write. And they're very firm about that. And then there are other writers who say, oh, yeah, every day is riders block until it's not. And then you have writers who, for a decade, don't write anything. So it's a fascinating sort of, there's a lot of variance in how we experience it. One of the things I like best, though, is the attitude of Jeff Tweedy,
或者至少是它的某种版本。但这却是一个两极分化的词，因为你跟一些作家交流，他们会说：“哦，我不知道你在说什么。那是一个荒谬的概念，我只是坐下来然后写作。”他们对此非常坚定。然后还有其他作家会说：“哦，是的，每一天都是写作梗阻，直到它不再是。”然后还有一些作家，十年什么都不写。所以这是一个迷人的现象，我们在经历它时存在着很大的差异。不过，我最喜欢的态度之一是杰夫·特威迪（Jeff Tweedy）的态度，
who is the frontman, the songwriter, the singer for the band, the rock band Wilco, and also himself a writer. He writes a lot of books and things like that. So he's a Renaissance man who his trade is really creativity. He has to wake up every day and be creative. And like any human being who's open and honest, he says, I don't wake up every day wanting to be creative. You know, my best creative force is not brought to the work that I'm doing every day.
他是摇滚乐队威尔科（Wilco）的主唱、词曲作者、歌手，同时他自己也是一名作家。他写了很多书之类的内容。所以他是一个全才，他的职业实际上就是创造力。他必须每天醒来都富有创造力。而且像任何一个开放且诚实的人类一样，他说：“我并不是每天醒来都想富有创造力。”你知道，我最好的创造力并没有投入到我每天都在做的工作中。
But he doesn't have the luxury, like a newspaper writer who needs to write a column, you don't always have the luxury of having writers' block. So what he has done that I think is really interesting is he thinks of his creative ideas, is as though what he has is essentially a body of water. And the clean, crystal clear water is at the bottom of this body, but on top of it sits a layer of muck. And the good ideas are covered by this muck. And the muck is, you know, I'm tired, I can't get motivated,
但他没有像报纸专栏作家那样需要写专栏的奢侈，你并不总是拥有不会遭遇写作梗阻的奢侈。所以他所做的、我认为非常有趣的事情是，他将自己的创意想法视为一处水体。而干净、晶莹剔透的水在水体的底部，但在它上面覆盖着一层污垢。而好点子就被这些污垢覆盖着。而污垢就是，你知道的，“我很累，我无法激发动力”，
and it's the sort of sense of writer's block. And he talks about pouring out the bad ideas metaphorically. And the way he does that is he'll sit at his computer, or he'll sit with a pad and paper, or he might sit at his keyboard or his guitar, thinking about how he's going to write a song. And he'll say to himself, the best thing I can do right now if I don't want to be stuck is to act. It doesn't really matter what the action looks like, but I need to act because then, you know, by definition, I'm not stuck. And so what he does is he says,
这就是那种写作梗阻的感觉。他谈到了以隐喻的方式倒出那些糟糕的点子。他这样做的方法是，他会坐在电脑前，或者拿着记事本和笔，或者坐在键盘或吉他前，思考他将如何写一首歌。他会对自己说：“如果我不想陷入困境，我现在能做的最好的事情就是行动。行动看起来是什么样子的其实并不重要，但我需要行动，因为那样的话，
in those moments for say 10 or 15 minutes at the beginning of the day, I'm going to lower my usually very high threshold for what's acceptable to the ground and say anything is good. Anything is acceptable for the purposes of getting the ball rolling. And so what he'll say to himself is something like, what's the worst musical phrase I could write right now? Or what's the worst passage that I could write? And the good news is, if you've been doing this for long enough, it's very easy to do a bad job. But it turns out to be better than doing no job at all.
根据定义，我就没有被困住。”所以他所做的就是，他说，在那些时刻，比如一天开始时的10到15分钟里，我要把通常非常高的可接受标准降到地面，并说任何东西都是好的。为了让球滚动起来，任何东西都是可以接受的。所以他会对自己说类似这样的话：“我现在能写出的最糟糕的音乐乐句是什么？”或者“我能写出的最糟糕的段落是什么？”好消息是，如果你做这件事的时间够长，要做好一件糟糕的事情是非常容易的。但事实证明，这总比什么都不做要好。
And that's what he's found, that it really does seem to propel him forward. And then after he's done that for a bit, he gets into the groove. And so for him, there is essentially no writer's block once he uses that tactic. And that's how I often think of writer's block, that as long as you act, even if the action is sideways, you'll get overriders block. It seems like one reason people get stuck these days, especially when they're trying to make a decision, is because there's so much information available at our fingertips right now. You give the example in the book of trying to decide what kind of car to get.
这就是他所发现的，它确实似乎在推动他前进。然后在完成了一段时间后，他就进入了状态。所以对他来说，一旦他使用了这个策略，基本上就没有所谓的写作梗阻了。这就是我经常看待写作梗阻的方式，只要你采取行动，即使行动是侧向的，你也能克服写作梗阻。看起来如今人们陷入困境的原因之一，尤其是当他们试图做出决定时，是因为我们触手可及的信息实在太多了。你在书中举了决定买什么类型汽车的例子。
What advice do you have for people when they get analysis, paralysis, because there's too much information to sift through? I think it's tempting to think of ourselves as a particular kind of decision maker. You know, like often we see our decision making as a sort of expression of wisdom. You know, I make good decisions. I'm a good decision maker. I make the right decision. I think a better way to think about decision making is to think of every decision in terms of its gravity.
当人们因为有太多信息需要筛选而陷入“分析瘫痪”（analysis paralysis）时，你有什么建议？我们很容易把自己想象成某种特定类型的决策者。你知道，通常我们将决策视为一种智慧的表达。你知道，我做了很好的决定。我是一个好的决策者。我做出了正确的决定。我认为看待决策的一个更好方法是根据其“引力”（gravity）来评估每个决策，
And to ask yourself, is this a case where I need to be absolutely right? I need to make the very best decision, which is known as maximizing. I maximize the outcome, or is this a case where I can, the alternative is satisfying, where I basically say there's a hurdle, I need to get over that hurdle, and as long as I come up against an option that's good enough, that's acceptable here. I don't need to find the perfect option. So there may be some areas of your life, for example, picking a partner or deciding whether they have children or deciding which house to buy or which town to live in or country to live in. Those are big decisions and I think they warrant a lot of care and attention. And so you should,
并问自己：这是一个我必须绝对正确的案例吗？我需要做出最好的决定，这被称为“最大化”（maximizing）。我最大化结果，还是这是一个我可以采取替代方案即“满意”（satisficing）的案例，我基本上是说这里有一个门槛，我需要越过那个门槛，只要我遇到一个足够好、在这里可以接受的选择就行。我不需要找到完美的选项。所以你生活中的某些领域，例如挑选伴侣、决定是否要孩子、决定买哪栋房子、或者在哪个城镇或哪个国家生活。这些都是重大的决定，我认为它们值得投入大量的关怀和注意力。因此，你应该
you should feel to some extent paralyzed by that decision and you should take a long time making it. But if you're standing at a wall of sodas at the supermarket and you're spending four hours trying to decide whether to go between Coke and Pepsi, that's a good case for satisfying. And I think most decisions we make during the day, even if there are hundreds of them, 99% of them probably fall in the satisfying camp. And there's a lot of research on satisfices versus maximizers, people who generally say good enough is good enough versus perfection is the only thing I'm looking for. If you hunt for perfection, you will be less happy, both with what you choose, but also in life in general. And so I think
在某种程度上感到被那个决定所瘫痪，你应该花很长的时间来做决定。但如果你站在超市的苏打水货架前，花四个小时试图在可口可乐和百事可乐之间做出选择，那就是一个适合“满意”法则的好例子。我认为我们白天做的大多数决定，即使有数百个，其中99%可能都属于“满意”阵营。关于“满意者”（satisficers）与“最大化者”（maximizers）——也就是那些通常认为“足够好就是足够好”的人与“追求完美是我唯一的追求”的人——有很多研究。如果你追求完美，你将会不那么快乐，无论是对你所选择的东西，还是对一般的日常生活。因此，我认为
learning to distinguish these cases where it's essential to make the right decision from the ones where it doesn't actually matter that much is a really useful life philosophy. I hope that comes as a relief to some of our listeners. Yeah. Since artificial intelligence is all over the news today's, I'd want to ask you if you've given any thought to how AI might help us get unstuck. And I'm thinking about a conversation I had with a colleague just the other day who had a work assignment where he had to synthesize a bunch of information and come up with recommendations. He didn't have a lot of time. He didn't see any immediate answer. So he turned to chat GPT, poured in the source information, and it spit out what he needed. So do you think generative AI is going to be
学会区分那些必须做出正确决策的情况与那些实际上并不那么重要的决策，是一种非常实用的生活哲学。我希望这对我们的一些听众来说是一种解脱。是的。由于人工智能如今在新闻中随处可见，我想问问你是否考虑过人工智能如何能帮助我们摆脱困境。我想到了我前几天与一位同事的对话，他有一项工作任务，必须综合大量信息并提出建议。他没有太多时间。他看不到任何直接的答案。于是他求助于ChatGPT，将源信息输入进去，然后它吐出了他需要的东西。那么你认为生成式人工智能会是
another answer to getting unstuck. Yes, very much so. Unfortunately, as an educator, I'm now stuck because half of the assignments I've assigned for the last 20 years are no longer viable. But my situation aside, I think it's a tremendous resource. And I think where it does its best work is, you know, we talked a little bit earlier about this idea of consulting others who are a bit different from you for advice and when you feel stuck. And I think chat GPT functions as essentially the collected wisdom of millions of different agents that are out there in the world because it's combing what's available on the internet. So generative AI for me is this great unsticking force that can be used as the kind of first step in the process, whatever the process might be. So I think that's usually
摆脱困境的另一个答案吗？是的，非常如此。不幸的是，作为一名教育工作者，我现在陷入了困境，因为我过去20年布置的一半作业现在都不可行了。但抛开我的情况不谈，我认为这是一项巨大的资源。我认为它发挥最佳作用的地方是，我们之前讨论过这种想法，即当你感到困境时，向其他与你略有不同的人寻求建议。我认为ChatGPT基本上发挥了世界上数百万不同代理人的集体智慧的作用，因为它在梳理互联网上可用的内容。因此，对我来说，生成式人工智能是一种伟大的“解困”力量，可以用作这个过程的第一步，无论这个过程可能是什么。所以我想这通常
where we get stuck. It's going from zero to one. And an example of this is if I'm sitting and struggling to write the beginning sentence of a chapter or the beginning paragraph of a chapter and I'm writing a book, which is something I've done a few times now, and I've often been stuck at the beginning of a chapter. It's a difficult thing to do. One thing you can do, and I have done this with ChatGPT occasionally, is you can say to it, I'm writing a book chapter, this is what the chapter's about. You can give it a brief description. Tell me five different ways that you could write this chapter.
就是我们陷入困境的地方。这是从零到一的过程。这方面的一个例子是，如果我坐着苦思冥想，想要写出一章的开篇句或开篇段落，而我正在写一本书——这是我现在已经做过几次的事情，而且我经常在一章的开头陷入困境。这是一件很困难的事情。你能做的一件事，我也偶尔用ChatGPT这样做过，你可以对它说：“我正在写一本书的一章，这一章是关于这个的。”你可以给它一个简短的描述。“告诉我五种不同的编写这一章的方法。
You could begin the chapter. Now, it doesn't mean you're plagiarizing, but what it's doing is it's getting you to think about some different options the way you might, if you'd spoken to five of your best writer friends, and they said, well, here's what I would do. Instantly, without having to check schedules and so on, you have this device or this platform that's telling you, here are five different ways to do it. And the nice thing about ChatGPT is if you say to it,
你可以这样开始这一章。”现在，这并不意味着你在抄袭，但它做的是让你思考一些不同的选项，就像如果你和你的五位最优秀的作家朋友谈过，他们说“嗯，我会这样做”一样。瞬间，无需核对日程安排等等，你就拥有了这个设备或这个平台，它告诉你：“这里有五种不同的方法来做这件事。”而ChatGPT的好处在于，如果你对它说：
let's imagine that the last thing you said was wrong, or let's improve on what you just did. It'll do that for you. And so you can push it and prodded in different directions. So I find it a tremendous brainstorming partner for that early phase where you feel stuck and where you're trying to move from, you know, zero miles an hour to maybe 10 miles an hour. From 10 to 60, if that's what your goal is, you might have to do that on your own, but it gets you started.
“让我们假设你刚才说的是错的，或者让我们改进你刚才做的事情。”它会为你做到这一点。所以你可以从不同的方向推动和敦促它。因此，我发现它是一个非常棒的头脑风暴伙伴，适用于你感到困境且正试图从“每小时零英里”移动到“每小时10英里”的早期阶段。从10英里到60英里，如果那是你的目标，你可能得靠自己去完成，但它能让你开始。
Let's talk for a moment about the role of fear in being stuck. Do people sometimes get stuck just because they're afraid of change or of the unknown? Yeah, so this survey that I've been running on people around the world, one of the questions I ask is, tell me what it feels like as you think about being stuck. and it's not surprising, I think, that the emotions they feel are negative. And fear comes up quite often. Anxiety comes up quite often. There's a real sense of isolation and loneliness,
让我们花一点时间谈谈恐惧在陷入困境中的作用。人们有时仅仅因为害怕改变或未知而陷入困境吗？是的，我在世界各地的人们中进行的这项调查中，我问的一个问题是：“告诉我当你想到陷入困境时的感受是什么。”我认为，他们感受到的情绪是负面的，这并不令人意外。恐惧经常出现。焦虑经常出现。有一种真正的孤立感和孤独感，
despite the fact that it seems near universal. It's often hidden from us that others are stuck as well. And I find one of the best ways to get over that fear of feeling stuck is to shine sunlight on this idea that being stuck is universal. And in fact, the beginning of the book, I spent quite a long time trying to be. figure out whether there were some classic examples of tremendously successful people from the outside who once you look at the process that was hidden from the world, you find, turns
尽管它似乎近乎普遍。我们常常看不到其他人也陷入困境的事实。我发现克服对陷入困境的恐惧的最佳方法之一，就是将阳光照耀在“陷入困境是普遍存在的”这一理念上。事实上，在书的开头，我花了很多时间试图弄清楚，从外部来看，是否存在一些非常成功的人的经典例子：一旦你审视那些被对世界隐藏的过程，你会发现，原来
out they were very, very afraid, very stuck, very uncomfortable until they weren't. And you find this with some of the biggest businesses in the world. I talk about Amazon and Airbnb. You find it with some of the most successful artists. I specifically focus at the beginning of the book on Brie Larson, the actress who won an Academy Award for Best Actress. And, you know, I, I I'm yet to find someone who says, in all honesty, I was never stuck. It was always easy. It was plain sailing. It was not an issue for me at all. And so, yes, going back to your question, I think fear is a very big factor that prevents people from moving forward. But so much of that comes from the sense that this is a sort of unique experience that I'm going through.
结果他们曾非常、非常害怕，非常卡壳，非常不适，直到他们不再如此。你在世界上一些最大的企业身上也能发现这一点。我谈到过亚马逊和爱彼迎。你在一些最成功的艺术家身上也能发现这一点。我在书的开头专门聚焦于布丽·拉尔森，这位获得过奥斯卡最佳女主角奖的女演员。而且，你知道，我，我——我还没遇到过谁能诚实地说：“我从来没有卡壳过。一切总是那么容易。一帆风顺。这对根本不是个问题。”所以，是的，回到你的问题，我认为恐惧是阻止人们前进的一个非常大的因素。但其中很大一部分原因来自于一种感觉，即我正在经历的是一种某种独特的体验。
And once you get past that, it usually feels, in my experience, quite liberating. And people do move forward. when a person's been stuck on something for a long time, how do they know when it's time to quit versus whether they should continue to try to push through? Is there some kind of a cost-benefit analysis that people could do in such cases? Yeah, it's a very interesting and important question. It's one of the big questions that comes up. In the book, I think I push quite firmly on the idea of persevering in general, because I think a lot of the research suggests there's a lot of value to persevering beyond the point where things get difficult. There are also some phenomenal
而一旦你跨越了那个阶段，根据我的经验，通常会感到相当解放。人们确实在向前迈进。当一个人在某件事上卡了很久，他们怎么知道什么时候该放弃，而什么时候又该继续坚持呢？在这种情况下，人们可以做某种成本效益分析吗？是的，这是一个非常有趣且重要的问题。这是出现频率很高的大问题之一。在书中，我对总体上要坚持不懈这一观点给予了相当坚定的支持，因为我认为很多研究表明，在事情变得困难之后继续坚持下去有很大的价值。还有一些非凡的
books, including a book by Annie Duke called Quit, which is about the opposite. How do you know when to stop? And obviously, a wise assessment suggests that you can't always push forward and you can't always quit. You need to know how to distinguish the two. One of the useful pieces of advice that I've come across from people who seem to find the middle ground quite well is they will describe a sense of convergence on an endpoint that they desire. So if you're learning a language or a skill or you're trying to produce a creative idea or you have a business or you're trying out a career or you're trying a new major in college, whatever it might be, you'll probably run into some hardship. You can't quit at the first sign of hardship. That's what a lot of the research suggests.
书籍，包括安妮·杜克写的一本名为《放弃》的书，讲的是相反的道理。你怎么知道什么时候该停下来？显而易见，明智的评估表明，你不能总是向前冲，也不能总是放弃。你需要知道如何区分这两者。我从那些似乎能很好地找到中间立场的人那里得到的一条有用的建议是：他们会描述一种向他们渴望的终点收敛的感觉。所以，如果你在学习一门语言、一项技能，或者你在试图产生一个创意，或者你有一家创业公司，或者你在尝试一个职业，或者你在大学里尝试一个新专业，不管它是什么，你都可能会遇到一些困难。你不能在遇到困难的迹象时就放弃。这是很多研究得出的结论。
But if all you're doing is slogging through the process and you don't feel like you're converging on something promising, rewarding, that makes you feel good, that brings you the emotional returns you're looking for, then at some point you do need to quit. And so one of the things you can do, sometimes there's an objective standard that helps you do this, but one thing you can do is to ask, am I getting closer to the goal over time? Am I converging? Is the gap between my current skill level or my experience now and where I'd like to be shrinking, or is it staying the same size, or is it even getting larger? And once it starts getting larger and you feel like you're getting further and further from where you want to be, I think you start to make a good case for quitting.
但如果你所做的只是艰难地熬过这个过程，而且你并不觉得自己在向着某个有前途、有回报、让你感觉良好、能带给你所期望的情感回报的目标靠拢，那么在某个时刻你确实需要放弃。因此，你可以做的一件事——有时有一个客观标准可以帮助你做到这一点——但你可以做的一件事是去问：随着时间的推移，我离目标更近了吗？我在收敛吗？我当前的技能水平或现在的体验与我想要达到的状态之间的差距是在缩小，还是保持不变，甚至在变大？一旦它开始变大，并且你觉得你离自己想去的地方越来越远，我认为你就有了充分的放弃理由。
But I think the idea of quitting as an empty idea doesn't make much sense. For me, it's always, what are you quitting to? What happens next? And so in my experience, when I've moved through different processes and when I've decided not to do something, the best thing you can do is really to line up the next thing and wherever possible, especially if it's a professional or creative endeavor. Now, in addition to your academic work, you do a lot of consulting with companies and organizations. I'm wondering if the advice you give them is similar to the advice that you give to individuals
但我认为把放弃看作是一个空洞的概念是没有太大意义的。对我来说，关键始终是：你是为了什么而放弃？接下来会发生什么？因此，根据我的经验，当我经历不同的过程并决定不做某事时，你能做的最好的事情确实是把下一件事安排好，并在可能的情况下，特别是如果这是一项专业或创造性的努力。现在，除了学术工作之外，你还为公司和组织提供大量的咨询。我想知道你给他们的建议是否类似于你给个人的建议
in terms of how to get unstuck. It's broadly similar. In the book, I focus on individuals to a large extent, but I also talk about organizations and management and marketing problems specifically. A lot of the ideas, I think, are leadership-oriented. You know, how do you put together a team? How do you put together a brain trust so that you maximize the chance of an organization unsticking? So there are some ideas that I think are germane to business decision making, maybe more than everyday life. But I always find, you know, I think
关于如何摆脱困境。大体上是相似的。在书中，我在很大程度上关注个人，但我也专门讨论了组织、管理和营销方面的问题。我认为许多想法都具有领导力导向。你知道，你如何组建一个团队？你如何组建一个智囊团，以最大化一个组织摆脱困境的几率？因此，我认为有些想法与商业决策息息相关，也许比日常生活更相关。但我总是发现，你知道，我认为
one of the big skills that we psychologists learn over time is that useful ideas have a lot of applications. And the best thing you can do is try to figure out where they apply. And often they apply more broadly than your instincts might suggest. And so I think a lot of the ideas, even, so here's an example, if I'm putting together a team and I'm trying to work out what sort of employees to put on that team, another question that you might ask, the individual version of that might be, I'm trying to put together a group of trusted people that I can turn to when I feel like I don't know how to move forward. And it turns out the same rules about composing that team at the workplace and in life, in general,
我们心理学家随着时间的推移学到的重大技能之一是，有用的想法有很多应用。你能做的最好的事情就是弄清楚它们应用在哪里。通常它们的适用范围比你的直觉所暗示的要广泛得多。因此，我认为很多想法，甚至——这里有个例子，如果我在组建一个团队，并且我正试图弄清楚该把什么样的员工放进这个团队里，你可能会问的另一个问题，其个人版本可能是：我正试图组建一群值得信赖的人，当我觉得自己不知道该如何前进时，我可以向他们求助。事实证明，在职场和生活中，关于组建那个团队的规则通常是
hold. And so I think you can learn a tremendous amount from the business ideas. And also the business ideas, I think, gain a lot from just what it is to be an individual human being navigating the world. Is there any other advice that we haven't discussed that you'd want to leave with our listeners today? I think one thing I'll say is we, in childhood, I have a five-year-old and a seven-year-old. And in childhood, there's a lot of curiosity. We find the world a curious place. We ask a huge number of questions.
相通的。因此，我认为你可以从商业理念中学到极其丰富的东西。而且，我认为商业理念也从作为个体人类在这个世界上航行这一事实中受益匪浅。还有没有什么我们没有讨论过、你想留给今天听众的建议？我想说的一点是，我们在童年时期——我有一个五岁和一个七岁的孩子——童年时期有很强的好奇心。我们发现世界是一个充满好奇的地方。我们提出了大量的问题。
we're very rarely satisfied by the first, second or third answers we get. And so we push forward constantly and, you know, kids are never satisfied with the answers they get. At some point between being a child and being an adult that shifts, we start to assume that common wisdom is common wisdom for a reason. Adults don't question that much. You know, you see other people doing something, you assume it's the right way where a child might say, why is that? And it turns out there are some adults who are natural, I call them experimentalists. It's a sort of philosophy of questioning everything and wondering whether with the right experiment there might be a better way.
我们很少对得到的第一个、第二个或第三个答案感到满意。所以我们不断地向前推进，你知道，孩子们对他们得到的答案永不满足。在从孩童到成人的某个时刻，这种转变发生了，我们开始认为常识之所以成为常识是有原因的。成年人不会那么多地去质疑。你知道，你看到别人在做某事，你就会认为那是正确的方法，而一个孩子可能会问：“为什么会这样？”事实证明，有些成年人是天生的，我称他们为实验主义者。这是一种质疑一切的哲学，并想知道通过正确的实验是否会有更好的方法。
Is there a better way for me to communicate with my loved ones? Is there a better way for me to work in the workplace? Is there a better way for me even narrowly to learn how to play a particular piano piece or paint a particular painting? It doesn't really matter the task. But one of the chapters I talk about these people who are chronic experimentalists, and how for some of them it unlocks tremendous potential. I talk about an Olympic swimmer who learned to be an Olympic swimmer at that level of proficiency
我与所爱的人沟通有没有更好的方法？我在职场工作有没有更好的方法？甚至往窄了说，我学习弹奏某首钢琴曲或画某幅画有没有更好的方法？任务本身其实并不重要。但其中有一章我讨论了这些长期进行实验的人，以及这如何为他们中的一些人释放出巨大的潜能。我谈到了一位奥运游泳运动员，他之所以能在那个水平上精通游泳
by essentially saying, hey, the way everyone else is swimming the backstroke is not the best way. He pioneered a completely new technique. And there are other people in other domains too. So I think that's a really valuable approach to the world that keeps us, A, young, and B, makes us open or keeps us open to the potential to do better in general. And I think it's one of the best ways to prevent yourself from getting stuck in the first place is to always say, oh yeah, this is starting to feel a little bit sticky. It's not working the way I'd like. I think I need to consider alternatives. And that's, I think, a very useful piece of advice. And what's next for you? What else are you working on besides stuckness? Yeah, so I'm constantly working on a whole lot of ideas. In fact, I talk about this in the book, that I have this document that's called research ideas. And another document,
本质上是因为他说：“嘿，其他人游仰泳的方式并不是最好的方式。”他开创了一种完全的技术。其他领域也有这样的人。所以我认为这是一种对待世界的非常宝贵的态度，它使我们A，保持年轻，B，让我们对做得更好的潜力保持开放。我认为，防止自己一开始就陷入困境的最好方法之一就是总是说：“哦，是的，这开始觉得有点卡壳了。它没有按我希望的方式运作。我想我需要考虑替代方案。”我认为这是一个非常有用的建议。接下来你有什么计划？除了卡壳之外，你还在研究什么？是的，我一直在研究一整套想法。事实上，我在书中谈到了这一点，我有一份名为研究想法的文件，还有另一份文件
called book ideas, and what they essentially are is 20 years worth of interesting ideas that have either come to me or that I've come across in the world, it would take me 100 lifetimes to actually pursue all of them. So at the moment, I'm very invested in the book and in the question of how we can get unstuck in lots of different contexts, but at some point I'm sure I'll return to those documents and figure out what's next. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Alter. This has been really interesting. Thanks so much for having me, Kim. Kim, I really enjoy it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combekingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts.
叫做书本想法，它们本质上是20年里出现的有趣想法，要么是我自己想到的，要么是我在世界上遇到的，我要花100辈子才能把它们全部付诸实践。所以目前，我非常投入于这本书以及我们如何在许多不同情境下摆脱困境的问题，但在某个时刻，我确信我会回到那些文件中去弄清楚接下来要做什么。好吧，奥尔特博士，我想感谢你今天能来。这真的非常有趣。非常感谢邀请我，金。金，我真的很享受。你可以在我们的网站www.w.combekingof psychology.org上找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的节目，也可以在苹果、声田、Stitcher、YouTube或你获取喜爱播客的任何地方找到。
And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA.org。本期《心理学谈话》由莉·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪永（Chris Condyion）。谢谢收听。我是来自美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。